[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dernière longueur de crawl pour rémy
camus il vient d'achever le premier tour
de france à la nage
son équipe est là pour le soutenir à son
arrivée sur la plage de monaco le jeune
athlète est sonné et bouleversé son
aventure a commencé le 1er juin dans la
mer du nord à dunkerque puis il a nagé
jusqu'à 13 heures par jour dans l'océan
atlantique
en tout il aura parcouru deux mille six
cent cinquante kilomètres en palme avec
un simple flotteur mais en découvrant
les eaux cristallines de la méditerranée
il ne s'attendait pas à être autant
bousculé méditerranée on me l'a vendu
qu'en maintenant une mer calme où tout
se passait bien et en fête premier jour
on essuie un orage et ensuite la
tramontane s'élever au niveau de
perpignan donc on a eu un mètre
cinquante de creux à en vomir 20 20 fois
dans la journée puis ensuite on a une
mistral tour de marseille donc ça pas
été une partie de plaisir mais ce tour
de france à la nage n'est pas seulement
un exploit sportif
rémy camusso être sensibilisés à
l'écologie et à l'invasion des déchets
du nord au sud de la france à 1 km de
littoral
il a nagé dans des eaux polluées par les
hydrocarbures des emballages plastiques
ou encore des pneus lorsqu'on arrive par
exemple dans la baie des anges qui n'est
pas très loin devant au niveau du cap
d'antibes mais à ces endroits là on a
une soupe de plastique et tout écrire en
italien donc nos déchets qui viennent de
l'italie pareil hein c'est pas une
critique c'est un constat les normes
environnementales
certains pays sont pas forcément les
mêmes que les nôtres donc à glee courant
on arrive à obtenir des déchets qui sont
pas qui nous appartiennent pas pour
expliquer sa démarche
cet aventurier de l'extrême se prépare
maintenant un autre tour de france celui
des écoles et des entreprises
toujours avec la même ambition protéger
une ressource essentielle universel et
fragile l'eau